welcome to my advanced edge paring
tutorial for the 5x5 cube this tutorial
will explain a faster method for solving
the edges of the cube this method
requires a lot of planning and looking
ahead and reduces wasted moves by
allowing the center's to remain sliced
although I figured much of this out on
my own I would like to thank Frank
Morris for his great website and virtual
cube diagrams I recommend that you
completely understand beginner edge
paring and can solve the cube in around
five minutes before attempting the
method in this tutorial so the concept
of this method is to slice the center's
to completely match up three edge pieces
forming what I call a treads piece or
triple edge piece once we build these
new tread pieces we're going to replace
them with an unmatched or mixed up
dredge from the top or the bottom phases
so to do that we can do one of two
things we can either lift the treads up
and replace it and then put the center's
back down or we can also kick it out
with the treads that we want so we would
kick it out and then we would fix the
center's and by doing that we have
effectively stored this new tread piece
on the top face so we're going to be
using the top and the bottom faces as
storage for these new treasures that
we're going to be building so once we
have done that we'll have 8 total treads
pieces so you should have a cube that
looks something like this
as you can see the top four treasures
are complete and the bottom four
treasures are also complete so what we
would do at this point is just realign
the center's and then we would solve the
remaining four mixed up treasures using
another advanced edging technique
alright so I'd like to make a
walkthrough for this cube that I've just
finished placing the center's on this
should give you some basic examples for
cases that you'll see when you're
solving your own cube all right so the
very first thing you should do is look
around the cube and see if you have any
edge pieces which may already be matched
up so I have these two matched up and
these two are also matched up even
though they're not directly next to each
other so I'm going to start with these
two what you want to do is you want to
just align them with their other edge
piece
if you don't have any pieces matched up
that's fine just pick two edges that
you'd like to start with so I'm going to
take this other outer edge piece and I'm
going to align it with these two then
I'm going to make my first slice so now
you should have some pieces matched up
and now that you've sliced the center's
horizontally you have designated where
you're going to be building these edge
pieces meaning in these middle layers
and where you're going to be storing
them on the top face and also the bottom
face alright so what we want to do is
you want to basically get this out of
the way and store it and replace it with
another mixed up dredge piece but we
don't want to just lift it up and
replace it with any mixed up dredge
piece we want to replace it with
something that will match up with one of
these side treasures so what I like to
do is I like to look for pieces which
may have white in them or which may
already be matched so I have a orange
and white piece here if I replace this
tread piece with an orange and white
piece that means I can match it up and
slice the center's back okay so I have a
orange and white piece here actually so
what I could do is I can bring this
around now if I want to match this piece
up with this one this white sticker
needs to go down here so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to lift that newly
matched dredge up kick it out with that
piece and then I'm going to realign the
center's now that this is properly
aligned I can match it up with the other
one looking around for the other orange
and white middle piece which is here so
what I need to do is I need to get the
white sticker here in this position so
I'm going to bring this down and now I
can kick this out when you kick it out
you're going to bring it up like that
but you mess up the center's so you kick
it out and you want to preserve these
edge pieces orientation to this one kick
it out flip it up bring this back down
and then bring this one back down and as
you'll see what that has done is it has
aligned this piece with these two so now
you have to do is just slice the
center's
and you have matched up another trench
piece and you have the newly formed
treads piece stored on top all right so
now what you do is look around next to
this one I have two pieces already
matched so if I could find the other
green and orange piece and put it in
this position then I could slice it and
form another tread so where is the other
green and orange piece it's right here
so what you can do you want Green to be
on this face so what you do is you bring
this here
flip that new be matched reg up kick it
out and then realign the center's now
you could slice this over and join it to
these two all right so now you have
another newly matched reg look in these
two positions for any matched up dredge
alright so here we have two red and
white pieces so what we want to do is
find the other red and white piece and
kick this newly formed dredge out with
that piece so looking around the cube
here is the other red white piece so
what we want to do is we want to bring
this piece and kick out this newly
formed reg so what we do we just bring
that newly formed edge down kick it out
and then realign the center's now they
are aligned to be matched up so I just
sliced the center's and I formed the red
white trench alright so look in these
two positions again I see that I have a
green and red piece here and I have the
other outer green and red piece here if
I want to get this piece here in this
position what I want to do is I want to
bring it here flip this up kick it out
and realign the center's now I could
slice this over and I've matched these
two pieces so you look around the cube I
have found the other red and green piece
I want to get this red sticker to be
right here so I bring this over here
flip that down kick it out with that
piece and then realign the center's now
I could slice it all
/ and I could join it with the other two
now I have another tread all right so
now if you look in the top face I have
one two three newly formed treasures and
I have one mixed-up one I want to get
four treasures basically stored in this
top face so what I do is I kick out any
of these newly matched edges kick it out
flip it around and I bring down this
mixed up dredge so now that I have four
here stored on the top face I don't have
to look at this face anymore to look for
pieces so I just flip the cube over and
now I can continue solving the treasures
all right so I have two pieces here two
blue and red pieces and here is the
middle one but as you'll see it will not
match up like that so what you need to
do is you need to get it into the top
face so you lift it up and you replace
it with any other mixed-up Treach it
doesn't matter so you lift it up replace
it and then bring it back down so now I
have these two pieces here and this red
and blue pieces over here so what I need
to do is I need to get the blue sticker
on this face so you bring that piece up
now blue is facing this way so I twist
it and kick that out and then I bring
the center's back down now I could slice
this piece over in between these and I
formed another trench so we look here in
this position all right so I have a
green and white piece here I have
another green and white middle piece
here Green is on this face I need to get
white right in this position so I bring
that sticker there and then I kick it
out bring the Centers down fix these
centers and then fix these centers now I
could slice this piece over and join it
to the other one so where is the other
green and white edge pieces right here I
need to get this green sticker right in
this position so I flip it up kick it
out realign the center's and now I could
slice and I formed another Treach
okay so just keep doing the same thing
over and over I have this piece here the
blue and yellow piece so as you'll see
these two pieces are not matched up
properly they're mismatched so what I
want to do this piece actually goes in
this position so I want to get this
piece here so I could slice it over so I
flip that newly formed treasure up kick
it out and then slice the center's back
down now when I slice this over it will
bring this one over here but it will
match up so now what I do with this
piece is I get it into the actually we
have completely solved so you sometimes
you'll think that you're you have to
keep on going but I have on I do have
one left here never mind okay so what I
want to do now is I want to get this
piece into the top layer so that I can
bring it down properly on the other side
so I lift it up and I take it out with
these pieces here lift it up replace it
with that edge piece and then bring it
back down alright so now what I want to
do I have these two blue and yellow
pieces here and now I have this piece
here I want to get blue I want this blue
sticker to be right down here so I'm
going to bring this here bring that edge
piece up kick it out and then realign
the center's now as you'll see I could
slice this over and I have completed the
last reg so you see I have one two three
four on the bottom and I have one two
three on the top and this is the last
one that I want to get in this position
so I kick out a newly formed tread
replace it with this last mixed up
dredge and then bring it back down now
all I have to do is realign the center's
since we have the top and the bottom
completely filled with dredge pieces so
you just realign the center's alright
now that you have four completed
treasures on the top face and also four
on the bottom it's time to solve the
remaining four mixed-up treasures
in the middle layers you can solve them
using the regular beginner method but I
prefer to use a simple two at a time
method because it saves time and moves
so what you do is you just find two
pieces that you want to match up all
right so I'm going to match these two up
first now when I match these two up I
have to slice the center's that way when
I slice them back I want to bring back a
yellow and orange piece so that I could
finish this tread as well so I find the
other yellow and orange piece which is
here and we're going to position this so
it is horizontal this way and this is on
top then I bring it and match it so in
order to get this yellow and orange
piece here I lift this up replace it out
and bring it down then I could slice the
center's back and I have completed this
tread okay so I want to pair this up
with that and when I do that I want to
bring this piece down to match up with
this one pair it up bring it up replace
it out with this piece and bring it down
and now I have completed this stretch as
well all right so as you'll see I do
have a parity error so what I would have
to do now is just can do the parity
algorithm
and I have completed all of the
treasures on the queue thank you for
watching my tutorial on how to solve a
5x5 cube with advanced edge pairing I
hope that the video has helped you out
be sure to leave any comments or
questions in the comment section below
and rate and subscribe for future
notification of my videos